i'd be personally in favor of of
delaying the draft uh so that we can get
some of the work done that that our
scouts and
and and our personnel people ordinarily
do and then just the logistics of
of trying to conduct the draft with
with uh uh you know you're not being
having not having access to your your
draft rooms in your offices you know
creates a lot of logistic uh problems
this is
this is not a fantasy draft
that uh um
you can conduct out there with just a
list of
of things on a piece of paper
[Music]
that's a long time saints general
manager mickey loomis on the peter king
podcast available now wherever you find
your podcast and mickey loomis chris not
the only general manager that would like
to see the draft delayed espn reported
on tuesday evening that the general
managers subcommittee voted six to one
to recommend a delay of the draft
because of the
inability to get full information due to
the covet 19 pandemic but also because
it's not a level playing field with some
facilities subject to closure and a
stay-at-home mandate so everyone's
working at home other facilities have
some degree of the ability of general
managers executive scouts to go and get
that information and work in that
setting that mickey loomis was talking
about so the nfl which is rarely
proactive and always reactive apparently
reacted to that complaint from the gm
subcommittee by issuing an order last
night that all team facilities will be
closed so it will be a level playing
field everyone's forced to work at home
through at least april 8 that's just 15
days before the draft and as to the
suggestion that the draft be delayed
chris we saw it happen last week for
free agency they're not delaying
anything they're going to have the stage
to themselves april 23 24 25 nothing
else in the sports world is going on it
is an equal hardship for all teams it's
going to be a test for all teams to make
chicken salad out of a bad situation and
everyone's got the same hardship the
same advantage the same disadvantage
there's no way they're going to delay
the draft they can crow all they want
about it the general managers the
coaches the owners it doesn't matter
they're not delaying the draft they're
going to go forward on the 23rd of april
i guarantee that
uh yeah i you know i mean listen if i'm
a gm or working in the front office i'm
mad i want the draft delayed but you
know chris sims here co-host with mike
florian pfd and a football fan damn i
want that draft to be at the end of
april i do yes we need action i think
it'll be good for our country i actually
think it's going to be really
interesting just to watch nfl teams kind
of squirm their way through the draft
with you know some unknowns maybe for
the first time now you know it's it is
tough uh you know to mickey loomis's
point i get totally where he's coming
from you know you were talking about you
know making million dollar investments
into people and now you're not going to
get a chance to meet some of those
people and really figure out who they
are you know scouts in certain regions
they're not gonna get to do all their
little due diligence and investigating
behind the scenes to go oh let me see
you know johnny's weight coach and see
if i can get some dirt on him to see
what he's really like as a person or you
know joey's uh you know athletic trainer
and see how he acts here accordingly you
know on a day-by-day basis those are
things that are going to go out the
window this year you're not going to
have like as in-depth reports on some of
these players because of the lack of you
know personal meeting time here right
now and that is going to make it very
hard on some of these front office guys
but but here's what you do you take the
rules that have been put in place by the
nfl and you get creative this is where
we're going to see the difference
between the smart organizations and the
not so smart organizations chris i had
this thought you know i that they'll go
to
a convenience store that is in the
neighborhood where a player lives and
they'll talk to the clerks they'll see
what kind of a i mean that's the kind of
stuff they do so what do you do now you
hire an investigator in that city if
it's a guy you really want to find out
more about instead of sending your scout
there you have to get more creative you
have to find other ways to solve the
problem don't just say oh well we're not
going to have the information you come
up with other ways to get the
information you come up with other ways
to assess the players and that's the
challenge we're going to find out who's
good at it and who's not and the nfl
doesn't care the draft is the ultimate
reality show about nothing they don't
care the teams are taking risks they
don't care that they're going to draft
somebody who's going to become a bust
they want to make it a show about the
process of picking the players and if
anything the uncertainty this year does
make it more compelling it will you're
right i mean i i would think the odds
are that we see more busts this year in
the draft because of that some you know
higher pick bus because you might not be
able to get to do all the things you
talked about but yeah you're right mike
teams better get creative if i'm the nfl
head coach and i want to draft like
justin herbert let's get on facetime and
talk for a long time but i'll be back at
pft with this crazy guy in a few minutes
we gotta go to commercial
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports